hi mari possa global thank you for your
questions i think is a great one my name
is true kotoka and i am an artist based
on Saucon Valley you heard so much about
the digital divide but I am also
interested that cultural divide your so
much to talk about the need for better
science and technology education but I
think there's an equally big problem of
inequality with cultural education and
that leads to a cultural divide and
there a couple of problems or matter the
first one is that art and culture are
allow you to connect with people who are
different than you are but art is
tremendous bridge if you want to learn
about the police or Africa or Asia the
best thing to do is to get a point in
with the art from that place as a
gateway to those people just like a
problem with the cultural divide is that
when you have it you're not able to
nurture creativity and young people and
art and culture stimulate associative
thinking which can help break
conventional ways of doing things and
that can lead to step function progress
and business technology politics without
culture I think we all become very
isolated
little ice world thank you very much